thank you
[Music]
reporting the news from Colorado
I love that place yeah it's beautiful
it's very beautiful Aspen very great did
you know that most of the people in
America live east of the Mississippi
oh east of the Mississippi
the most of the population is on that
side and then most of the population on
the west coast is just by California
like basically the West Coast like San
Francisco yeah and then so when you go
like Nevada Utah Colorado Arizona all
the middle part right there that's
barely anything that is excellent
excellent backstory to this Colorado
news all right so a woman has been
seriously hurt
after she was placed in a cop car right
for a road rage incident the police put
her in this cop car and then and she was
in the back seat and it was closing all
that stuff and they went to go figure
out more [ __ ] about the situation and
then the car that they left her and got
hit by a freight train oh no way why was
he parked on the
facts yo what the [ __ ] did that happen
Colorado because there's so few
electrical lights if you look at a map
of all the population so they couldn't
see anything yeah you're either on the
east of them he thought the train was
all the way did that [ __ ] roll back
perfectly under the tracks it was in
neutral was it an assassination
no she's not dead she's not dead but
she's seriously injured [ __ ] Iron Man
dude lawsuit yeah the Colorado Bureau of
Investigation says multiple law
enforcement agencies responded to a
report of a road rage incident involving
a firearm in Fort Lupton on Friday
evening and then a Platteville police
officer stopped the woman's car just
past a set of railroad tracks and parked
the patrol vehicle on the crossing why
would they do that what and do they not
have the thing that goes
yeah the two minutes of warning so does
her accident cancel out her crimes
the
did you ever see how [ __ ] slow those
[ __ ] go they go slow
I think this will got too comfortable
you don't have cops when they pull
people over they always they're just
like they just go like this they just
get out and just leave the car
it doesn't matter if they're going to
7-Eleven [ __ ] Rouse wherever they're
just so [ __ ] used to it maybe he's
just so used to it that he didn't even
think there's gonna be a railroad or a
[ __ ] train coming so he just left the
car there he's like [ __ ] get in the
[ __ ] car and then Freight trade comes
yeah I gotta fill out some paperwork I
mean parking enforcement does that [ __ ]
too yeah you see them get out to ride
tickets all the time just leave their
car in the [ __ ] road maybe her car
was in front of the track so when his
car was there it was just like
that's a good hack though if you're
being pulled over just find the nearest
track and just stop right in front of it
and then take the hit and then
until they're like move forward oh my
God I'm surprised she's alive man been
hit by a freight train yeah cause
usually when you pull over on a freeway
right cops will tell you get off this
yeah exit because they don't want to
[ __ ] walk by and then like yeah get
some weird [ __ ] I like to watch those
videos on YouTube where it's a
compilation of buses and trucks and
stuff hitting cop cars because they're
out there giving a ticket I'm just like
that's just wild dude send me that link
send me that long
yeah I think the idea of uh any
just human being being like all right
I'm gonna park my car on this railroad
crossing I think like that's just the
base level that's where it all went
wrong it doesn't matter what profession
you hold what your purpose is [ __ ]
even an ambulance you know if you're
there to repair the railroad you would
park on the railroad to repair it you
know hey there's no time man the trade's
coming
you know what they need to bring back
now I'm telling you that was a gen Z cop
because that means they never seen those
old [ __ ] movies or even cartoons or
Thomas the Train we're like no not
Thomas the Tank Engine but those girls
that were always like strapped to this
the rails I mean when they're like tied
up and [ __ ] they're like they're like
old westerns and then the [ __ ] chain
comes and then the evil guys on the
train
meanwhile it's all to old school jazz
music and stuff like that and he's black
and white and you can't hear anything
they're just like Tech spot because we
grew up with those cartoons and we know
the reference like oh dude there's a
train coming like don't stand there but
then these new kids they're like the
[ __ ] is a locomotive
what the hell is that she's cop with his
whole life not knowing now that I think
I think maybe this was I told you it's
assassin it's a assassination she's a
very VIP because he left for doing what
yeah what was he doing what was the
problem so it says uh the woman was
placed in the back of the police vehicle
which was hit by the train as officers
were searching her car the suspect name
and details of her injuries have not
been released so maybe they were pulling
over somebody for road rage but really
it was this chick that they needed to
off by way of private they got some good
assassins in Colorado man because that
is really weird that they parked on the
railroad though like for anybody just a
normal person you would just that's like
almost like a level like assassination
101 move right that's like chapter two
Italian mob like you know play somebody
in a [ __ ] car and then watch it
either be blown up by way of ignition or
you're on a railroad Cross or you take
her to a road yard like a junk junk
guard and they [ __ ] smash the car
yeah that's how Mobsters do it but do
they kill them first
but that's like when you get picked up
by a magnet and [ __ ] too so they got
like the two ways to scare you you
already are like [ __ ] peeing in your
pants and stuff yeah on your way
I like the classic blow up thing you
know the little click boom yeah either
any the second you do something it just
blows up very uh Godfather but they they
failed at Ed Rosenthal didn't die
because they failed in the movie Casino
you see when he goes
and you think he's dead they cut back
and you're like he made it made it yeah
so there it's a survivable thing just
like the railroad
well you got to make sure the bomb is
you know
a lot of them
you can't just put a little bit and go
let's kill this guy he's like you gotta
put enough you gotta put a lot of bombs
in there what is this bear it's about
how many bombs there's too many bombs
that's true you can't have too many when
you try to kill somebody but then if you
get too many you might kill some
innocent people so that you want the
perfect amount because if it's too much
then then you're a terrorist collateral
because you just took down the whole
Casino you just want the parking lot in
the casino you just want the person and
then the evidence to go that's true damn
that that is really hard yeah to have
the perfect amount and you don't
want to spend too much
yeah I'd be like
albums yeah and you bought a bombs
you're wasting all the money yeah
which is exactly why when you don't even
have to buy a bomb because you can just
join the police force park them park
anywhere you want including a railroad
crossing you get to waste money when
you're a cop because it's not your money
if you waste the cop the the citizens
money if she survives it must be pretty
clear that the cop car wasn't fully on
the track
probably hit like yeah yeah probably
wasn't like direct yeah so maybe he
wasn't complete he thought he was out of
the way and a [ __ ] white body trains
just came through you know said she was
seriously injured so that means there
had to be some like pretty horrific
damage it's either they're really dumb
or this is premedited that should be a
fatality on most cases like they just
didn't realize what the [ __ ] they were
doing I think when yeah when they don't
give the information of the other person
too why would they withhold it's under
investigation that means we're handling
it internally you don't you didn't know
it I you didn't have her ID yeah why are
you holding it back they're saying the
Fort Lupton Police Department is
investigating the road rage report while
the Colorado State Patrol is
investigating the crash
Colorado Bureau of Investigation is
looking into the woman's injury while
she was in police custody and nobody
knows their name no other information
they won't release the name where's the
list exactly well did she have something
to do with Epstein's list that's why
they try to kill her exactly
she probably did 911 too while we're at
it wow
if it happened right Jason that's what
you're telling me I'm not in this I'm
not in what are you you're right here I
want you to say I Jason Chen hi Jason
Chen I'm not in this don't believe that
911 happened do you believe 911 was
inside job it happened was it inside job
you said that I Jason Chen music never
sleeps the singer
um oh I remember lion and Evan I was at
my uncle's work Ryan and Evan
it's still my best friend lion and Evan
we were hanging out but it wasn't not
here it was in Taiwan I remember so you
weren't even here yet no so your your
love for America came after we got no
it's what I said no is when I saw that
it happened and I said nobody should
ever do that
and that's when I came you're a patriot
brother you saw the Twin Towers get
attacked and you said Imma Be American
yeah wow I saw I just want to let
America know thank you for your service
that I came at the at when America
needed us love and then that's when you
got your Pilots training when did that
happen that was right after nice yeah at
12 years old 11. oh you were 11 when you
came over with line and Evan exactly
you guys know me so well
foreign
[Music]
[Music]